كان الشعب اليهودي هنا منذ
3500 عام ، حقيقة أن اليهود يعيشون هنا
وسيستمرون في العيش هنا وسيستمر
الفلسطينيون في العيش هنا وسيتعين علينا أن
نعيش معًا
ولن نقوم بتطهير
عرقي قلب  الشعب اليهودي
لن نذهب إلى عشائر عرقية إسرائيل 20 من
سكان إسرائيل هم من العرب
ولن نقول إننا لن نحقق
السلام حتى نطرد العرب من
إسرائيل ولن نحصل على السلام
حتى نطرد أه اليهود من
هذه المناطق المتنازع عليها فهي
ليست غير شرعية فهي مناطق متنازع عليها والطريقة
الوحيدة لحل هذا الخلاف هي إجراء
مفاوضات سلام مع
الفلسطينيين باستمرار برفض
الدخول الآن أعتقد أننا نستطيع  توقف عن الحديث عن
هذا الأمر ، وقد قال الناس في الماضي أنك
تعرف ما لم تحل هذه المشكلة ،
وما لم يكن لديك سلام مع
الفلسطينيين ، فلن تحصل على
سلام أوسع مع العالم العربي ، لذلك لن يكون
للفلسطينيين الذين لا يفعلون ذلك لمدة 25 عامًا  لا يريدون
السلام مع إسرائيل يريدون أن يروا سلامًا
بدون إسرائيل الذين لا يريدون أن تكون دولة
بجانب إسرائيل ولكن دولة بدلاً من
إسرائيل لديهم حق النقض (الفيتو) الفعال على
توتر EXP لدائرة
السلام حولها.
ذهبت مباشرة إلى الدول العربية
وصاغت مفهومًا جديدًا للسلام من
أجل السلام من خلال القوة. لقد
صاغت أربع اتفاقيات سلام تاريخية هي
اتفاقيات إبراهيم أبراهام وهو
ضعف عدد اتفاقيات السلام
التي جمعها كل من سبقوني في 70 عامًا.
أسألك عن ذلك
لأنني أعلم أنك ملتزم جدًا
باتفاقات أبراهام التي تعد إنجازًا كبيرًا
من قبل الرئيس ترامب وبواسطتك وأعلم
أنك تريد الاستمرار في
ما يحدث عندما نقول إن
الجائزة الكبرى هي أعني  تعرف أن
بعض دول جنوب شرق آسيا هذه على الطاولة مطروحة
على الطاولة ، لكن
السعر الكبير هو المملكة العربية السعودية ، من الواضح أن
ما يحدث عندما تحصل المملكة العربية السعودية على
الولايات المتحدة لتتماشى مع بعض الأشياء
التي يريدونها من الولايات المتحدة.
الإجراءات الأمنية لكنهم يقولون ، انظروا إلى
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ، من المحتمل أن
يسموكم ،
أنا بحاجة إلى شيء للفلسطينيين
من أجل مواكبة هذا الأمر ، لا يمكنني
فعل هذا مع الفلسطينيين
المهم بالنسبة لي
ودائري ، ما الذي تريده؟  هل
أنت على استعداد للسماح للناس في
الضفة الغربية بالتصويت ، هل أنت على استعداد
للسماح لـ 300000 عربي المقيمين
في القدس الشرقية بالتصويت جيدًا ، فأنا
بالتأكيد على استعداد لأن يكون لديهم جميع
السلطات التي يحتاجون إليها لحكم
أنفسهم ولكن لا شيء  من القوى التي
يمكن أن تهددنا وهذا يعني أن
إسرائيل يجب أن تتحمل
المسؤولية الأمنية الغالبة لأننا في كل
مرة نخرج فيها من لبنان ، نقول إن
إيران جاءت مع وكيلها
حزب الله ، خرجنا من غزة
أو إسلاميين راديكاليين آخرين
استولت عليهم حماس و  إذا ابتعدنا فقط
كما يقترح الناس أه عندها
ستنتقل حماس وإيران إلى التلال المحيطة
بالقدس المطلة على تل أبيب ،
لذلك أعتقد أن هناك
معادلة للسلام ولكن وجهة نظري
بسبب حقيقة أن
الاستمرارية  الرفض الفلسطيني المستمر الذي
يعود إلى قرن من الزمان للاعتراف بدولة
يهودية كدولة قومية للشعب
اليهودي في أي حدود
يستمر الرفض المستمر إذا
انتظرناها لن نحظى
بسلام قال الناس إن عليك أن تعمل في
طريقك للخارج  في أول قطعة من الداخل إلى الخارج
مع الفلسطينيين السلام مع
العالم العربي ، أعتقد بشكل واقعي
أنه سيكون العكس ،
لكن هل أنت إذا توصلنا إلى سلام مع المملكة العربية
السعودية ، فهذا يعتمد على
القيادة السعودية ونجلب
الصراع العربي الإسرائيلي بشكل فعال إلى  في النهاية ، أعتقد
أننا سنعود إلى الفلسطينيين
ونحصل على قطعة عملية مع
الفلسطينيين أعتقد أن هذا ممكن وأعتقد أن هذه هي
الطريقة للذهاب في أحد أكثر
الشهور دموية في إسرائيل
والمنطقة التي شوهدت أه منذ سنوات وسنوات
كانت هناك  أطلق النار على سبعة إسرائيليين خارج
كنيس يهودي عند مدخل
كنيس يهودي يوم الجمعة ، وهو
اليوم الدولي لإحياء ذكرى الهولوكوست ، الذي جاء بعد
يوم واحد من مقتل 10 فلسطينيين
بعد مداهمة في الضفة الغربية
خلال مداهمة في الضفة الغربية في جنين ،
وعدت بإطلاق نار قوي  ورد سريع
على إطلاق النار على الإسرائيليين ، ما مدى
قلقك بشأن كل شيء
يخرج عن نطاق السيطرة كما
رأينا للأسف يحدث في الماضي ،
أعتقد أن هناك دائمًا خطر
من ذلك وأنا أفعل كل ما في وسعي
لاحتوائه أه أنا  يمكن أن أقول لكم أن
السنوات العشر الماضية التي كنت خلالها كنت
رئيسًا للوزراء كانت الأكثر أمانًا أه وهدوءًا
في تاريخ إسرائيل ، لكن كان علينا بشكل دوري
اتخاذ إجراءات سريعة وقوية
ضد الإرهابيين ، لا أؤمن
بالعقاب الجماعي ولكني أؤمن بالعمل
المركز  كلاهما ضد
الإرهابيين أنفسهم هذا العمل الذي
أشرت إليه كان عملًا ضد أه
المخابرات التي أعطتنا قنبلة موقوتة جماعة
إرهابية كانت تهدف
لقتل الإسرائيليين ولحسن الحظ
طردناهم للأسف قتلت امرأة
في ممر المشاة
مدنيًا ولكن  ما واجهناه في
العامين الماضيين بما في ذلك في
الحكومة المنتهية ولايته كان مضاعفة
الهجمات الإرهابية من
المناطق الفلسطينية لأن السلطة الفلسطينية
لم تكن تمارس حقًا سلطتها على
أه لمحاربة الإرهابيين لذلك كان على
الجيش الإسرائيلي أن يأتي و  كان علينا أن
نأتي في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية أيضًا ، فأنا
أتخذ إجراءات مستهدفة ضد
الإرهابيين ، دائرتهم المباشرة من
أنصارهم الذين شاركوا في مساعدتهم على
القيام بأعمال الإرهاب أو الاحتفال
بالألعاب النارية والحلويات وأشياء أخرى
بعد الأعمال الإرهابية  لذلك
نعتقد أنه إذا اتخذنا إجراءً مستهدفًا
ضد الإرهابيين
ودائرتهم المباشرة أه ، فقد يؤدي ذلك في الواقع إلى تقليل
الحافز لما نسميه
الإرهابيين المنفردين ، فهم ليسوا وحدهم
داخل سياق ولذا تريد أن
تستهدف  لكن استمروا في استمرار الاقتصاد واستمروا في
عمل 150 ألف فلسطيني
في إسرائيل. لم أغلقها ولو
لدقيقة ولا أنوي ذلك